welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel studios newest hero is
confirmed to be
oscar isaac as moon knight in the
upcoming marvel disney plus series aka
mark spector a vigilante possessed with
the power of the egyptian moon god
kunchu
who suffers from dissociative identity
disorder also taking identities of
millionaire stephen grant and taxi
driver jake lockley
all in order to help him stay close to
the streets to fight that crime but
lately in comics he has appeared as the
white suited mr knight
this is huge news guys oscar isaac is
arguably the most serious acting
heavyweight marvel has gotten for a
title role in one of their disney plus
shows
he's a crossover performer in pretty
much every title in our nerdy multiverse
from star wars to
into the spider-verse to the fox x-men
movies to
dune to niche sci-fi stories like
ex-machina and annihilation
the guy can do it all and it sounds like
he's going to be continuing to do it all
within the mind of mark spector who
carries multiple personalities in his
head all
at once so who talks first you talk
first i talk first you talk first i talk
about
so first now moon knight might be a new
name to you if you're not caught up on
the marvel comics so i'm gonna break
down who
moon knight mark spector is but more
importantly why he's gonna be so
important to the marvel cinematic
universe's future okay so mark spector
was the son of a rabbi
and he trains as a boxer becomes a cia
agent though in later comics he's a u.s
marine
but then as he works as a mercenary he
comes across the egyptian moon deity of
khonshu a god that possesses his body
and gives him supernatural strength and
reflexes and abilities all based on
where the moon
is in its lunar cycle and he later takes
on alternate identities back in america
initially he's the millionaire steven
grant in order to hide from his
mercenary past but then he becomes the
cabbie jake lockley so that he can roam
the streets as a crime fighter
but the later and best known
explorations of moon knight retconned
his egyptian origin story as a possible
symptom of dissociative identity
disorder making mark
question whether these alternate
identities and superpowers are
objectively
real via conscious or subjective
projections
delusions coming from within his own
mind now i can confirm that we have not
found any mentions or sightings of moon
knight or more expector throughout the
mcu so far
some have said that you might be able to
see moon knight's ankh in doctor
strange's sanctum sanctorum but not from
any of my obsessive frame by frame
analyses of the sanctum and doctor
strange thor ragnarok or infinity
war so where is it in captain america
winter soldier jasper sidwell mentioned
a
man in cairo as a project inside target
a tv anchor in cairo the under secretary
defends a high school valedictorian iowa
city
that almost certainly was not mark
spector he was never a tv anchor but
rather this seems to be a reference to
the egyptian media during the arab
spring
but here is what we do know about the
marvel cinematic universe and how it
pertains to
mark spector's introduction to this
universe first the upcoming marvel
disney plus titles will be
aggressively interconnected with the
writers from each series sitting in
on the writers rooms of other series for
example jessica gao the show runner of
she-hulk sat in on the writer's room of
moon knight
now before she-hulk jessica gal wrote on
rick and morty writing episodes like
pickle rick
and a lot of her co-writers on rick and
morty are overseeing
a big chunk of marvel phase four titles
rick and morty writer mike waldron is a
showrunner on loki
and he's also writing the latest draft
of doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness and then another rick and morty
writer
jeff luvnis is writing ant-man 3 a story
that with kang will probably deal with a
lot of quantum realm
timeline crap so you can see how this
whole mcu
vision is being constructed by the
people behind one of the greatest
multiverse properties on tv right now
now in moon knight's case it was just
announced that the show runner is jeremy
slater who developed and wrote the
umbrella academy on netflix
also a series that explored time travel
and timeline manipulation now there are
other details we know about how the mcu
could set the stage for moon night look
i know there's a lot of clues we gotta
sift through
because the best visual clues are hiding
in plain sight just
like someone's front pocket wallet like
the ridge thanks to
the ridge for sponsoring this episode
the ridge helps you carry what you need
every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want you to make the most
out of what you're bringing with you the
ridge wallet is made out of military
grade materials like titanium and carbon
fiber
it has a clean stylish design it is
so when jason voorhees is trying to kill
you he won't be able to kill your credit
cards
this is their aluminum silver wallet
they do have other colors including some
very flashy tiki designs
this thing is light it's strong just
like you
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee it's also got 30
000 5 star reviews so you know they're
doing something right they also have
great backpacks and travel bags with
rfid
blocky pockets and the optional device
charging batteries get 10
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to ridge.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description okay so the fact
that moon knight is joining the mcu
right as marvel builds out its
interconnected multiverse is interesting
especially when you consider marvel
also appears to be extending backward to
incorporate ancient deity figures
based on set photos the eternals will
explore the old gods of earth
and their ancient history set partially
in ancient egypt
which i have speculated before could be
used to establish the origin of mutant
kind in mcu with figures like the first
mutant
apocalypse whom oscar isaac
coincidentally
played an x-men apocalypse so maybe that
could be a way they established konshu
in this universe and thus moon knight
but we also
just got a big one division clue from
that wakandaphiles book a marvel in
universe companion guide in which
shuri notes that the mind stone ionized
wanda's nervous system
charging it to give her neuroelectric
interfacing to create bursts of extreme
energy
and manipulate minds to plant suggestive
thoughts and enhance
pre-existing paranoias one thing that i
think we've gotten from the one division
trailer is possible evidence of
manipulation by marvel's devil figure
mephisto
who could be hijacking wanda's mind to
help
manifest these illusions illusions that
could be objectively real
depending on wanda's ability to control
this inner power and it's just
interesting to note how thematically
linked
that story is to the story of mark
spector
just like him wanda maximoff as well is
trapped in various alternate identities
trying to determine which is the true
reality
so could this story give us a clue in
how marvel will introduce
moon knight well the master theory i've
been exploring in recent marvel videos
is how one division being moved to the
first official marvel phase 4 title
tells us something about the studio's
big plan that they're going to open this
era with a story that could end by
shattering the mcu into a multiverse of
madness
flooding it with dark forces unleashed
from the pandora's box
of wanda's hellscape mind wanda's
demonic manipulator is mephisto
and her battle with him could cause her
reality bubble to
burst allowing other spirits from the
underworld to scatter
across the world and latch onto other
earthly forms
one of those could be konshu attaching
to mercenary mark spectre
scrisic like the other unstable mind in
the marvel world wanda maximoff
mark spector moon knight could be
suddenly possessed by this dark spirit
battling it in his mind for control and
then have these werewolf-like
lunar nighttime attacks caused by that
other inner entity
taking over and based on jessica gao's
cooperation behind the scenes
mark spector's after hours rampages
through new york city
could lead to him needing some legal
representation which could set up
a partnership with a certain attorney
jennifer walters
she-hulk and who knows maybe that
journey to control that magic could lead
mark to the steps of 177a bleaker street
in midtown
with doctor strange arming him with an
ancient egyptian relic
the ankh that may or may not be among
those artifacts and this i just hope
leads to the establishment of stake
special threat assessment for known
extra normalities
and the midnight suns in the mcu but i'm
getting ahead of myself there's a lot of
goodies that could come from this i
don't know from you how do you think
moon knight will connect to marvel's
phase four plan
join the nerdy conversation on our
official discord server by becoming a
patron at patreon.comrockstars follow me
on instagram at eavos follow new
rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything you love
thanks for watching boom night
[Music]
you